last question today is from Ashley
Ashley says what is the most memorable
class that you've ever taken now Pat
when I read this I didn't know if it was
referring only to like college or high
school and college because you know I
think one of the most memorable classes
that I had from from elementary school
was was um when you do those experiments
where you combine baking soda and
vinegar and my mind was just blown and I
think I just remember it because it was
so different than sitting there learning
math or counting or reading or whatever
but from high school one of my most
memorable classes was AP economics where
my history teacher who also with the AP
economics teacher said I think you might
do well in AP economics and that class
started me on my path down an economics
education which I pursued as one of my
two majors in my undergraduate studies
as well as one of my two concentrations
in graduate work doing my MBA so in
terms of impact and and how memorable it
is that's definitely there and then as
far as College goes certainly when I
took a class with Richard Wolffe who's
been a frequent guest on our program he
taught economics at my undergraduate
alma mater the University of
Massachusetts and that was a very
memorable class because he also gave a
Marxist approach to economics which
differed so greatly from the traditional
rational economic perspective of my high
school classes that it really just
opened up my eyes opened up my mind in
so many ways so those are the ones that
strike me so for me the class that was
the most memorable was also the class
that was the most rewarding which would
had to be a senior year in high school
English class that was geared towards
preparing students to go to college the
next year and because of that it was
kind of outside of the molds that we had
learned in preceding years in high
school it was less about the five
paragraph essay and it was more about
you know argumentation and investing
your own personal experiences and
anecdotes and thinking outside of the
box as to what is acceptable in a kadhi
I guess you'd say and so you know we
thought about you know critical thinking
philosophy all these big heavy topics
that really challenged us and we would
also learn vocabulary words that were
actually useful in that we would be
using in college in the next few years
so things like zeitgeist you know
ambivalent blasted all words they still
use today use flash at all the time all
the time that's interesting yeah yes so
uh do you when you think back to high
school in college and you can separate
them if you want do you think that what
you what was most important that you
learned in high school and college was
specific facts or knowledge or was it
more generally how to think or approach
problems I think you know the answer
here it's all about critical thinking
that's probably the most important
lesson that you'll learn from both high
school and college especially nowadays
because I mean specific facts and
information you can look up so easily
what's harder and what sets you apart is
your ability to apply that knowledge
because now you know basic facts the
atomic mass of carbon or like who is the
13th President United States that's
common knowledge now anyone can know
that within a few seconds so I think
it's all about you know knowing the
surrounding information and how to apply
it I think I've talked about this a
little before in the questions about
whether I debate politics with people
outside of the show the ability to think
critically is so lacking right now that
I basically if I can't avoid getting
into a political discussion and you know
Pat that there's a guy on our floor in
you know where the studio is who's a big
right winger and will just engage me in
random things I will not even present
facts or make an argument I will merely
ask questions to try to get them to
examine their belief so usually either
like this guy the other day said
something like yeah but you know the
problem is all media is left there's no
source it's all media is liberal so I'm
not surprised that they're talking about
Trump Russia and I said really how do
you determine if media overall is left
or right
didn't really have an answer but it got
him thinking the answers were completely
bogus that he came up with and then I
said and and how much are you watching
of what's out there
do you think it's a representative
sample and if just for a second I can
get the other individual to question not
the facts but how they came up with
their beliefs I feel like that's as good
as I can basically do right now and the
lack of critical thinking and ability to
figure out you know basic epistemology
why do we believe what we believe
I don't like getting into political
debates randomly throughout my life I
get enough of it on the show but I am
actually getting somewhere I feel like
by just asking these types of questions
getting people to think about how did I
arrive at my beliefs because it's not
something people tend to think about do
you don't annoys me even more though is
when you come across person a person who
you realize you're not going to have
much in common with when it comes to
politic and so they divert the
conversation all about more virtuous
things like you know we can agree to
disagree or is McCreight that we live in
a country where we can have these
differences of opinions and we can you
know make our arguments and disagree
with each other but at the end of the
day shake hands because we're all one in
the same I mean it's just it's just kind
of hokey I think I really don't care for
that sort of stuff yeah it's like I'd
rat if we don't want to have political
disagreements let's just not talk about
politics or even the ability to not have
to agree on politics let's just talk
about something else
there's lots of other things that we can
talk about I had a situation like this
recently with someone that I know is
like a big right-wing conservative
Christian whose politics are the
opposite of mine and I was not
particularly looking forward to to
having a conversation with this person
but I knew like we're just not going to
talk about politics they know what I do
I know their views let's just pretend
that we neither one of us has any reason
to talk about those things and just talk
about something else and we did caught
up for five minutes and then moved on
and I'm happier with that this is why
you watch sports you have to watch sport
although sports have gotten pretty damn
political lately uh but but that's sort
of in a different way I guess we could
say okay three great questions hopefully
some meaningful
answers we will talk to you next on the
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up and get instant
access to the members only bonus show
which we do every day for you